don't hesitate go commit you gotta
commit telling somebody to shut the [ __ ]
up at the right time is the right thing
life is dangerous and the only way to
really enjoy it is jump and be free need
motivation what top ten would believe
nation
what's that believe nature that's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who went from
being a great student in school to
refusing to go to college because he
wanted to rap to becoming one of the
most powerful men in Hollywood
he's Will Smith and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success vol 6 also
if you want to know what Will Smith and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that it was so strange
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one commit fully life is hard right like
yeah you might get hurt it's like you
know you're you you know your heart
might get broken you know it's like you
might lose your job but you still gotta
commit you know and it's like you know
you meet somebody and you hey you know
you like her and she likes you and you
hesitating
don't hesitate go commit you gotta
commit you know you might get hurt you
might lose something but it's like you
can't experience the the joy that is
intended for you in life if you don't go
you gotta go man
rule number two serve others I think
what makes a great emcee is the same
thing that makes a great father it makes
a great husband makes a great politician
makes a great human being and it is your
commitment to your personal evolution
your personal growth for the purpose of
assisting others like you know I'm
working on this record now called up
it's called the mountaintop and the the
ideas I've been to the mountaintop right
and it's like I'm gonna do reports from
the summit right I've been to the top of
money I've had all the sex that I've
ever wanted
I've had all of the adulation and and
adoration and I've been to the top of
all of those material world mountains
and nothing makes you happy other than
being useful to others that's it's the
only thing that ever will satisfy that
thing is that what you are is useful
growth one of the favorite things I love
to do is create all inspiring
experiences that cultivate growth that
cultivate wisdom that you know elevate
understanding so when I go subway with
my kids I always want to push them I
just want to push the envelope slightly
and get as you say you get out of that
comfort zone just a little bit that's
where your growth space is so watching
somebody experience wonder and all and
grow that's I just love to do however we
can build that rule number four jump and
be free we not just bungee jump it on a
helicopter
we're gonna do it at the grand camp and
when I was up there red and I jumped I
realized you know it's fun and it's
exciting and there's something
mythological about confronting death
right because as much as we're laughing
and as much as we're having
it really is the emotional confront with
death you know and I'm 50 years old now
and I'm sort of having the realization
that you you have to be able to go
[Music]
you have to be able to take that shot at
the thing that you dream you have to be
able to take that shot at that that love
that you want that life that you want to
build and it's like you know when I was
up there and the guys said to me the
only way you can get hurt
is if you don't get away from the
chopper right and he said in that moment
he said we're gonna let the courts go on
these courts weigh 200 pounds right so
when we let him go they're gone
the hesitation is the thing that really
messes up the chance at having your
dreams right get out of the middle
push it off is pure frickin terror I
think there's a moment of falling but
you guys so it's really that you can do
just like life there's nothing to hold
on to and we're all trying to hold on to
something you're trying to hold on to an
idea or you're trying to hold on to a
person and there's nothing to hold on to
and we gotta just get comfortable
following knowing there's nothing to hit
right you know and that's the idea it's
like life is dangerous and the only way
to really enjoy it is jump and be free
rule number five feel the moments you
challenge yourself a lot of times I mean
what is even when rap you was like I did
I dare rapper to write a verse verse
without occurs yeah so what is it now
you think you've loosened up kind of on
us that's more like you don't mind yeah
you know for me it's um it's it's much
more about authenticity one of the major
things was the idea of duality right
the idea that right and wrong aren't
separate things they're together right
so something that happens to you is the
best thing and the worst thing that
happens to you you can't you can't
separate them like they go together
everything has its yin and it's yang and
you can't get around it so the idea that
my grandmother teaching me about
profanity during that time was what
worked to help elevate my career that
helped elevate my experiences but it's
not necessarily right to not curse you
you curse when it's the right thing not
gratuitously not good to try you know
it's like when it makes your point like
telling telling somebody to shut the
[ __ ] up at the right time is the right
thing just everywhere right
so it's like given myself rather than
specific hard and fast rules and
paradigms now I'm trying to feel the
universe and feel the moments and feel
the opportunities for what is right for
me in this moment rule number six take
responsibility for your happiness me and
Jada was reflecting about love and I
asked her I said what does she think was
you know one of the biggest revelations
that she had had about love she said
that you cannot make a person happy and
I thought that was a real deep idea you
can make a person smile you can make a
person feel good you can make a person
laugh but whether or not a person is
happy is deeply and totally and utterly
out of your control
I remember today I retired I literally
said to Jada that's it I retire I retire
from trying to make you happy I need you
to go make yourself happy and just prove
to me that is even possible and after we
cracked the hell up we started talking
about we came into this false romantic
concept that somehow when we got married
that we would become one and what we
realized is that we were two completely
separate people on two completely
separate individual journeys and that we
were choosing to walk our separate
journeys together but her happiness was
her responsibility and my happiness was
my responsibility and we decided that we
were going to find our individual
internal private separate joy then we
were going to present ourselves to the
relationship and to each other already
happy not coming to each other
begging with our empty cups out
demanding that she fill my cups and a
cup and demanding that she meet my needs
unfair and is it's kind of unrealistic
and can be destructive to place the
responsibility for your happiness on
anybody other than yourself rule number
seven love yourself
I believe that self-discipline is the
definition of self-love that when you
say that you love yourself that means
that you have behavior towards yourself
that is loving it's like you say to
yourself a man look I know you want to
eat that pizza and it'll be really good
you know but I can't let you eat that
man cuz if you eat that pizza you gonna
feel like you know and I I just I love
you too much to let you eat that and I
think the word discipline has kind of
gotten a bad name we think about it in
terms of punishment I'm not talking
about discipline in that way I'm talking
about discipline in the sense that you
you forego immediate pleasure for the
exchange of long term self-respect
self-love is when you say to yourself
man look I know you and that girl got a
real connection
I know y'all vibe but yes your girl's
cousin so I love you too much to let you
do that self-love is a look I know you
got a a test on Monday you know and I
know you really want to go out with your
friends is Saturday night you want to go
out but if you fail that test you're not
gonna feel good about
yourself you know I just I love you too
much to let you go out tonight
self-discipline is self-love if you want
to be happy you have to love yourself
which means you have to discipline your
behavior the road to sustained happiness
is through disciplining your behavior
rule number eight have role models you
had great success obviously at the box
office but you know you did your thing
on a small screen to show called The
Fresh Prince yeah man the team on that
show was ridiculous Quincy just he knows
how to put stuff together James Avery
was relentlessly on me to elevate like
James Avery wouldn't give me a damn inch
like everything I said everything I did
for James Avery was like nope not good
enough you know he was like if you you
have this position look where you are
look what you are blessed with it was
like I'm sorry but I'm not accepting
anything other than absolute committed
perfection from you and at that time I
was bawling you know and James Avery
wouldn't give me nothing and it's like
he was he was the model for me of an
actor you know so the craft it's like
James Avery was no bull like he was so
like serious and like I would look at
him and and he just had that acting
power that I wanted to have right rule
number nine don't let fear stop you
[Music]
my parents drove us cross-country - we
were going to California for a family
reunion so we drove to the Grand Canyon
and we got there and I like I remember
having a deeply meaningful experience of
how beautiful it was but I was terrified
to walk up to the edge and all my
brothers and sisters and my whole family
walked up to the edge and I stayed back
just scared to to take in beauty if
you're scared you're not going to take
the chances that you need to take - to
realize your dreams and that was the
thing for me I don't mind being scared
but I'm still gonna do it and rule
number 10 the last one we for a very
special bonus clip is have fun listen
listen I'm sorry I'm sorry
look here's the deal this is a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity for me
man all right just you already won man
let's go use dragon I'm black ain't
nobody gonna know the difference I got
it I got it ready I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
you better win that you better
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Will Smith on how to be confident in
your abilities that I think you're going
to enjoy but before that it's time for
the three-point landing questions time
to move from just watching another video
to actually taking action in your life
or your business and if you're feeling
bold leave your answers in the comments
below here we go question number one
what is fear stopping you from doing
number two how can you jump and be free
and number three who are your top three
role models
Denzel was the only person that I looked
at on screen I was like I just can't do
that
like I you know he just he just got a
thing that was so extra that I just felt
like I couldn't I could never I could
never live up to that but for the most
part when I look at people and I when I
looked at things I always feel like I
can when I look at J right now I see I
said I can't do that when I see stuff I
can't do when he when he writes though
the way he writes the way his mind works
I look at J I'm like I can't do that I
looked at Eminem I was like I can't I
can't do that you know this is right but
for the most part I don't I don't live
in a space if I can't I live in this
space of I feel confident that if I put
in my 10,000 hours that I can I can
achieve anything
if you want to learn how to be
unrealistic and the best of Will Smith
motivation check out the link right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy
the video continue to believe and I'll
see you there you don't say I'm gonna
bake this build the biggest baddest
greatest wall that's ever been built you
don't start there